it's our dear friend of the show who's
been here since the beginning it's ayton
burnett
[Music]
i'm so excited to ask you some in-depth
questions
i know you and your work ethic with you
i actually really want to expose how
damn hard you work thank you i mean it's
crazy eitan yes i've one of my biggest
things to work on this year has been
work-life balance i do not usually have
that i like to film in the mornings like
i'll start filming around like 5 30
film for a while in the morning and then
i used to work till 11 p.m let me tell
you that's not healthy so i've been out
working on working until like six and
try to have a fun night after but it's
definitely a lot of a lot of work goes
behind
how long did it take you to sense
burnout
and go i do need balance i think
recently one thing i've worked on is
trying to figure out to prioritize my
time okay what do i need to do what can
what can i have other people help me do
i think burnout's real even no matter
how much you love something if you do it
too much you're going to get burnt out
so i think that was something that was
important and just kind of making that
shift you are a very smart savvy creator
do you have any advice for someone who
might be watching about process channels
what is some advice i always try to
think about like as if i'm the audience
like so if i'm creating content for tick
tock i'm like okay what is what do i
want to watch from on tick tock tick
tock the audience sways younger if i'm
doing for facebook okay it's an older
audience for instagram it's more kind of
like a wide gamut of an audience and
just thinking about like if i'm the
audience what do i want to see so it's a
sunday morning what type of recipe do i
want that day what's my attention span
as the audience sometimes you know the
audience can sit down and watch an
hour-long drew brian moore show
sometimes they can watch a 15 second
tick tock and i think just trying to
figure out like what do people want to
see what's their attention span it's
really important and then how can i best
like entertain them and i think my
biggest advice is just planning every
little aspect what i do i try to plan
and if things are planned calendar
blocks set yourself deadlines think a
lot of times in social media since your
own boss it's important to set deadlines
how did you figure out how to angle your
camera and do your editing style because
i feel like you were very original fresh
and first to bat with that type of style
yeah how did it come to you when i
started on tick tock i was one of the
first food craters on there so you kind
of really had to invent the wheel and i
think for me interesting we're like what
what is the most captivating on tick
tock you have such a short attention
span you know people are there scrolling
on the train and they're at their
doctor's office and they're bad like
they don't they don't want to sit there
for a while so i'm like alright what is
the fastest way to control something the
most compelling way the most dynamic
i'll place my phone down and then i'll
grate the cheese over the phone on
falling onto the cheese and you get that
like cascading shot today i'm showing
you how to make the world's cheesiest
mac and cheese so i wish i think what's
the most dynamic way you know i only
have a few seconds to entertain someone
so i just want to entertain educate and
have fun in the process when you think
people have short attention span let's
keep it at the portal tick tock they're
in a cab subway doctor's office how do
you understand that on a tactical level
but not take it personally emotionally
oh yeah it's definitely times when you
go in the analytics and you're like okay
people only watched
eight seconds of this like the average
view time let's say it was set 10
seconds of this 15 second video like
wait what what about the other five like
i worked on those but i think it's just
important to know like even prior times
okay what a lot of times in a recipe
i'll look at a recipe and maybe when i
write down the recipe i tell you to do a
first and then b and then c but in the
video i know that's b is the most
interesting so i'll actually try to
figure out how i can move b to the
beginning get that most interesting
compelling part and just kind of do it
sometimes a little backwards for the
video just so that people are
entertained and kind of get them engaged
let me ask you a few advice questions
for people out there if you see a bad
comment what do you do okay so this is
something that i feel really passionate
about and i think because i've been
doing this since i was 12 and i'm sure
you could probably relate you've been
doing it since you were younger whenever
you're in the public eye or people are
watching you or you're doing something
out of the norm people have opinions the
way i think about it as someone who
works in social media is
negative comments pay the bills haters
pay the bills that's why we say haters
are the ones who comment the right
paragraphs telling you how horrible you
are and i'll tell you this the instagram
tick tock facebook youtube algorithms
they don't know what the people are
saying they just know they're saying it
and then they're interested and they
show it to more people so haters pay the
bills that's what i say
[Music]
i love that true oh i love that and
they're your biggest fans because they
will watch every single video you post
so they can hate on it and they just
help you
see i just stay away from the comments
and i learned to do that as a kid
because your people were like don't read
the reviews yeah because it's just like
social media training you are going to
get half that are positive half that are
negative the middle people just they
don't count they don't care enough to
comment and then what is the validation
you're basically at zero it's a fine
line between you know like filtering out
the haters and being able to opie open
and take like real criticism haters make
you is one of my favorite things i've
ever heard because i want people to find
a strength and a sense of humor
about the fact that it's almost a
guarantee you're going to get 50 like
and dislike and there's no end game
which is saying i think also you're like
in a constant
like competition with yourself there's
no like oh i hit a million followers i
won
great like there's always more always
more you could do so it's also important
just like make sure you're happy that
you're like you're enjoying the process
not the end goal because there is no end
goal well work hard play hard actually
and
i certainly did for a long time
fantastic advice eitan as usual
you remain my hero thank you my dear
friend and i'm just so glad that we
found each other i mean i really have
been doing this show with you since the
very beginning and i want to ride
into the science here
yes love you love you too oh thank you
thank you
[Music]